but first we start tonight with joe
biden projecting weakness
on the world stage frankly it's an
embarrassment and america's enemies they
are taking note tonight
from cyber attacks to proxy wars you
have an alliance that has emerged with
iran
and russia and china yep all ramping up
their
malignant activity on friday the largest
oil pipeline network in the u.s was shut
down
because of the cyber attack reportedly
linked to
hillary's favorite country of russia
this pipeline transports nearly 50
percent
of all gas consumed on the east coast of
this country
and that's including fuel that is used
at our military bases so make no mistake
this was a major attack and not only are
gas prices already skyrocketing
they will go higher now gas stations we
can report at this hour
they're actually starting to run out of
fuel and our military was also impacted
so the pressing question of the night
joe how will you respond
my guess is they will do absolutely
nothing well you might want to call
hunter he got the 3.5
what million dollar deal with the first
lady of moscow
the wired money from the russian
oligarch and after all joe biden is
doing very little we also have china's
military their expansion into the
pacific and
the arctic even as china is publicly
threatening australia with a long-range
missile
attack and a strike and in february joe
rewarded iran we told you about this
by ending u.n sanctions put into effect
by donald trump
and his administration and remember iran
is
the world's number one state sponsor of
terrorism and as we speak
the hostile regimes get this they
continue to fund
proxy wars across the region a few days
ago
the u.s navy intercepted the ship in the
arabian sea
enroute from iran to yemen what was in
that ship it was carrying
a massive amount of missiles grenade
launchers
sniper rifles other chinese and
russian-made weapons
bound for the ongoing proxy war in yemen
against the saudis by the way so that's
russia
that's china and that's iran fighting a
proxy war
against a group we're now aligned with
that would be the jordanians the
egyptians
the emirates israel and yes the saudis
who would have thought about that five
years ago
earlier today the terrorist group hamas
backed by iran
in their charter they called for the
destruction of israel they launched a
rocket attack on the holy city of
jerusalem
this hours later israel responded with
force they attacked hamas targets in
gaza
and following the strikes the israeli
embassy in the u.s tweeted quote
imagine if a terrorist group was firing
rockets at washington d.c
or london imagine the people of paris or
tokyo
running into bomb shelters israel will
defend itself from attacks on its
capital
now joe biden he needs to decide
are you going to defend israel joe and
of course if you watch this program you
don't have to imagine what's happening
in israel
we have been on the ground in israel
we've been there during these rocket
attacks
now we showed you the playgrounds that
kids play with
they're indoors in a bunker constructed
in a small israeli town
border town with gaza why because in 10
years they had 10 000 rocket attacks
and it made it way too dangerous for the
kids to play outside
so kids play in bunker playgrounds
underground
we also showed you the elaborate tunnels
constructed by hamas
used by terrorists to bypass border
security
carry out attacks in israel these
tunnels by the way
were constructed with american and
israeli funding
israeli-american concrete and
electricity
all meant for hospitals and schools and
infrastructure
real infrastructure not joe biden child
care infrastructure
this is why the trump administration
stopped and halted
millions and millions of dollars in aid
to palestine
instead of helping the palestinians the
money now joe biden pledged
over 200 million dollars now a year
that funds the terror group hamas which
rules palestine with an
iron fist but guess what biden's already
reinstated that aid to the tune of
hundreds of millions of dollars
and lo and behold now that they have the
extra money
the rocket attacks are back again sadly
didn't have to be this way there's never
been a greater ally to the state of
israel
than former president donald j trump not
only did he move the u.s
embassy to jerusalem something many
presidents promised but never followed
through on
but his peace through strength policies
his steep financial sanctions on
america's enemies
restored order to the middle east and an
alliance that nobody ever thought
possible
and the abraham accords and let's not
forget about the near
miraculous peace deals all brokered by
the trump administration
let's see between israel and multiple
arab states
sadly some republicans hated trump so
much they were willing to risk
all of this just to get him out of
office one of course is congresswoman
liz chaney
she helped joe biden get elected chaney
clearly has her own agenda
and that is her prerogative liz is out
for liz fine liz
have at it she's willing to help the
radical socialist left
if that means hating all things donald
trump she's out of touch
with the republican party and the base
of the republican party
and her constant lecturing constant
divisiveness
not helping the gop having her own
agenda and prioritizing that
over that of the party well that can't
move the country forward
and don't listen to the noise in the
media they don't really like liz cheney
either
and now with the biden administration's
foreign policy in full effect
liz are you happy do you feel the world
safer
it's time for republicans to get it
together and do what they can to oppose
this administration these dangerous
policies
on the world stage and by the way before
we move forward with breaking news north
carolina governor
roy cooper has now declared a state of
emergency
over the temporary outage of the
colonial pipeline
caused by the cyber security attack that
all signs
point to russia about it's getting
serious hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else